[Applaudissements]
lorsque l'on m'a proposé de venir vous
parler d'écologie si ce soir je vous
avoue que j'ai longtemps hésité
je me suis dit mais j'ai pas de
connaissance concrète sur le sujet j'ai
pas d'études a cité j'ai pas de chiffres
à donner
puis je vous respecte trop pour vous
faire un spectacle de marionnettes parce
que je suis une très mauvaise
ventriloque
et puis je me suis souvenu d'un recueil
intitulé le développement de la personne
que j'avais étudié en psychologie
où l'auteur carl rogers disait ce qui
est le plus personnel et le plus
universel
en plus clair ça signifie que c'est
lorsque l'on parle des détails de
l'intime de l'unicité d'un parcours
qu'en réalité on parle de tout le monde
à tout le monde
alors j'ai pensé à mon parcours
à celui d'une enfant frustré à une
adolescente sur sur consommatrices puis
une adulte plus consciente
en plus théorique comment je suis passé
de l'ignorance des problématiques
climatiques à une écologie individuel
puis collectif
en plus métaphorique si vous préférez
comment je suis passé de bourgeons à
arbre puis fauré
en parlant de forêt j'ai grandi dans la
vallée de chevreuse un endroit très
privilégié au sud de paris de la verdure
des beaux villages un très bon système
éducatif et des familles aisées
tout
non une famille peuplé d'irréductibles
prolétaires résister encore et toujours
à l'envahisseur
je pense que vous avez compris
c'était la mienne
ce qu'il faut saisir c'est que j'ai très
vite vu qu'il y avait des différences
entre eu mes camarades d'école et moi on
n'avait pas les mêmes vacances pas les
mêmes jouets pas les mêmes vêtements
et j'ai un sentiment d'injustice qui a
grandi en moi
et qui s'est même progressivement
transformée en colère
et à ce moment là je me suis fait une
promesse que lorsque je serai grande moi
aussi j'achèterai tout ce que je pourrai
et même ceux dont je n'aurais pas besoin
eh bien devinez quoi
c'est exactement ce que j'ai fait
quand je suis devenue indépendante
financièrement j'ai fait du shopping
toutes les semaines j'achetais des
tonnes de maquillage pas cher sur
internet et j'avais une cinquantaine de
paires de chaussures à talons alors
qu'en vrai je savais pas hyper bien
marché avec
enfin j'avais tout comme mes camarades
de l'époque
mais il y avait un truc qui clochait
moi qui avais tant attendu tout ça moi
qui avait tant rêvé de tout ça
et bien maintenant que c'était là bas je
ne sentais pas complète je dirais même
plus j'avais l'impression que plus je
possédais et plus je me sentais vide
mais alors on m'avait menti
on m'a toujours dit que c'était ça la
réussite que c'était ça l'objectif
si c'est pas ça
alors c'est quoi
je devais me rendre à l'évidence
j'allais devoir me poser deux trois
questions sur ma conception du bonheur
mais comme je suis une grande enfant
j'ai eu envie de le faire sous forme de
jeu parce que la remise en question ok
mais de manière ludique s'il vous plaît
alors j'ai décidé de me lancer un défi
par an dont le but serait de nous priver
pendant une année d'une habitude pour
constater la place qu'elle prenait dans
ma vie et surtout de voir si j'étais
capable de vivre sans elle
en 2015 j'ai fait un encens fast food au
début c'était clairement pour ma santé
et puis je me suis renseigné sur
l'industrie agroalimentaire derrière à
la fin de cette année 2015 je suis
devenue végétarienne
en 2016 j'ai fait un temps où j'ai pas
acheté de vêtements au début c'était
clairement pour une question de place
dans mon logement et puis je me suis
renseigné sur l'industrie textile
derrière
à la fin de cette année 2016 j'ai vendu
les trois quarts de ma garde-robe et je
n'ai plus jamais remis les pieds dans
une grande enseigne
en 2017 j'ai fait un temps où g ramasser
tous les déchets sur mon chemin
au début c'était clairement pour
améliorer mon environnement visuel
proche et puis je me suis renseigné sur
l'industrie plastique derrière
à la fin de cette année 2010 est je me
suis juré de ne plus participer à ce
tsunami jetables
et c'est ainsi qu'en 2018 j'ai fait mon
dernier défi où mon premier selon comme
on le voit un an sans produire de
déchets
armée de livres de conférences de compte
instagram je me suis lancé j'ai acheter
des sacs en tissu j'ai fait mes courses
au marché j'ai acheter en vrac je suis
passé aux cosmétiques solide bref je
suis tombé dans la marmite du zéro
déchet et petit à petit mes engagements
même rayonner encore plus grand j'ai
boycotté les multinationales j'ai arrêté
de prendre l'avion j'ai changé de voie
professionnelle et je me suis même
embrouillé avec des gens de ma famille
comme tout une personne qui se remet en
question
et c'est ainsi que par des défis un peu
égoïste et un peu lancé sur un coup de
tête à la fin de l'année 2018 tous mes
déchets rentrer dans un bocal grand
comme ça
et là c'est le moment où vous dites 1
c'est après tout ce cheminement qu'elle
s'est sentie complète
et bon risque de vous décevoir pas
vraiment
et j'ai mis un moment avant de
comprendre pourquoi
il ya deux raisons à ça
la première c'est que j'ai réalisé que
tout mais avancée écologique
individuelle était intimement liée à
l'augmentation de mon niveau de vie
quand j'étais plus jeune et que ma
préoccupation principale c'était comment
on va payer le loyer à la fin du mois
savoir ce que ma bouteille en plastique
allait devenir c'était un peu le dernier
de mes problèmes
à mesure que j'ai eu plus de temps plus
d'argent et moins de charge mentale j'ai
pu enfin me poser des questions qui
dépassent est ma propre survie
et la deuxième raison c'est que j'ai lu
une étude du cabinet carbone 4 de 2019
dans laquelle il était écrit que si
individuellement on était hyper engagé
et bon réduire notre empreinte carbone
de 25 %
alors 25% c'est super
mais le reste
si même lorsqu'on est presque héroïque
ça suffit pas
alors à quoi ça sert
c'est pour ça que je me sentais pas
complète parce que j'ai compris qu'on
pouvait pas tout c'est rigolo et que
même si c'était le cas eh ben ça
suffirait pas
je vous avoue qu'à ce moment là ma vie
j'ai eu envie d'acheter un 4 4 et
d'aller cramer de l'essence partout
parce que foutu pour foutu autant se
faire plaisir tu vas
mais j'avais un problème principal
c'est que j'ai pas le permis
donc il fallait trouver une autre
solution
et comme toute personne un tantinet
désespéré j'ai eu besoin de parler
donc j'ai commencé à lancer la
discussion avec des amis j'ai rejoint
des associations j'en ai parlé sur
internet bref j'ai vidé mon sac pour
éviter de couler et par ces échanges
j'ai su que ce que j'avais ressenti
quand j'avais eu envie de cramer de
l'essence partout ça porte un nom ça
s'appelle l'écho anxiété c'est le terme
que l'on a donné pour désigner toutes
les angoisses qu'on peut tout et tout
ressentir quand on pense aux changements
climatiques
et non seulement j'ai appris que j'étais
pas la seule à le ressentir mais qu'en
plus était capable de dépasser ça
et en vrai la solution elle est venue
presque instinctivement
parce qu'à force de ressasser ensemble
nos questions nous avancer nos limites
et bon à créer de l'énergie
et cette énergie est devenue concrète
salvatrice en fait cette énergie nous a
donné envie d'agir d'agir ensemble et
d'agir sur le terrain et puis il
suffisait d'ouvrir un tout petit peu les
yeux pour se rendre compte qu'il y avait
déjà des choses qui existaient les
composts de quartier les jardins
partagés les marches les maraudes les
actes de désobéissance civile d'autres
avant nous avait fait ce cheminement
d'autres avant nous avaient combattu
l'anxiété en se bougeant et on a pu voir
que ça fonctionne je pense notamment à
la ville de détroit qui est devenu un
exemple d'agriculture urbaine locale une
fois que les entreprises sont partis
après la crise où la ville de femmes à
tina en argentine où depuis 15 ans et
habitant et ses habitants tiennent tête
aux gouvernements et ont pu faire
interdire 5 projet de mine d'or
et puis en france aussi où suite à la
pétition la sphère du avec l'an 2019 qui
avait réuni près de 2 millions de
signatures pour la première fois de
l'histoire l'état français a été
condamné pour inaction climatique
c'est là
c'est là que je me suis sentie complète
non pas en achetant tout ce que je
voulais non plus en adoptant un mode de
vie individuelle radicale mais en
sortant de ces deux visions
l'une consumériste et l'autre classiste
c'est en rencontrant d'autres humains et
en ayant envie de faire des choses avec
eux
or la question qu'on peut se poser après
tout ça c est du coup est ce que les
petits gestes servent à quelque chose
moi j'aurais tendance à dire oui
parce que certes on sauvera pas le monde
en triant nos déchets ou en achetant nos
fruits et légumes chez le petit
producteur
mais je pense que ces petites actions du
quotidien peuvent nous mener vers des
réflexions beaucoup plus grande
parce que si on fait marche arrière dans
tout ce que je vous ai raconté
c'est parce que j'ai arrêté de manger
des burgers en 2015 que ce soir je suis
face à vous
alors j'ai envie de vous poser la
question
quel sera votre défi un peu égoïste et
un peu lancé sur un coup de tête qui
changera votre vie est peut-être le
monde avec merci
merci